mais je trouve que c'est intéressant
donc vous l'avez compris la d'épissage
alain g chelle s'est posée bien après
mon départ du ministère mais je suis
étonné vous me citiez monsieur raout
quand même parce que je vous réponde ses
propos on ne sait pas moi qui les cités
c'est le professeur flahault man donc
pardon il dit faut tester tester tester
je suis en tous les cas le 24 février
j'ai les propos du professeur groupe le
24 février suis parti le 15 il dit il ya
plus de morts par accidents de
trottinette en italie que deux mordus
coronavirus il dit qu'il ya cette date
il ya que 504 coronavirus dans le monde
ça devrait arrêter la panique et qu'on
est proche de la fin d'épidémie donc je
pense pas que ce soit fin février qu'il
demandait conteste je veux bien
reprendre des propos plus tardif si vous
voulez encore
voilà je crois c'est pas la peine je
peux vous prendre pour prendre mes
collègues
voilà donc ce n'est pas voilà je
quittais pour ça que j'ai reçus en
traction de contraction du temps si vous
voulez je crois que la question des
dépistages à large échelle elle s'est
posée au mois de mars mais pas avant
merci catherine des roches
oui premier point oui c'est pas moi qui
ai cité le professeur out je vous ai
rapporté les propos du professeur
flahault
voilà alors après vous nous dites
c'était ultérieure jeux lontan et bien
évidemment néanmoins il était important
pour nous d'avoir votre votre avis sur
ce sujet